[Music]
today is a product of pure frustration
uh which could probably describe every
daily cancellation i could really
describe every moment of every show
i'm gonna be canceling two of the most
inane
incoherent irrelevant misleading uh
talking points that always come up with
any high-profile police shooting
um and i you know we've mentioned these
in the past but i think i think
it's time that we really focus on them
for a moment at least
these are and they've especially reached
fever pitches in response to the micaiah
bryant incident
these are talking points that reveal a
fundamental misunderstanding of the law
of the real world you know and they are
these
number one why can't the cops
just shoot the person in the leg and
there's been a lot of that
number two why did fill in the blank
black suspect get shot if dylan roof the
charleston church shooter was taken
alive
must be racism those are the two you've
seen these talking points a lot
i hear them all the time so let's take
these one at a time starting with number
one
why can't the cops shoot in the leg well
as it happens the police
chief in um columbus ohio was asked this
this very question by a member of the
media and uh
he provided the answer i think let's
listen to what he has to say
couldn't have just shot her in the leg
so she throw up could he have shot her
in the arm something like that
right you know one of the uh the
difficult things with that is
um when you're trying we we don't train
to shoot the leg
because that's a small target we train
to shoot center mass what is available
to stop that threat
there was a threat going on a deadly
force threat that was going on so the
officer is trained to
shoot center mass the largest part part
of a body
that is available to them when you try
to start shooting legs or
arms rounds miss and then they continue
on and there are people behind that
that could be in danger that are not
committing anything uh so we try and
minimize
any danger to anyone else if we have to
use our firearm
so i think he successfully answers that
question and it should be enough
for anyone who was seriously confused
about it i think the answer you just
heard there is good enough but to
emphasize
his point let me add that though i am
not a law enforcement officer
i do realize one fundamental fact
we are not living in a john wick movie
okay in the real world john wick doesn't
exist
and the guy who plays him keanu reeves
is a 56 year old dude
who probably can't do 12 push-ups and
certainly can't single-handedly dispatch
um a whole room full of mob hitmen okay
that in the real world that doesn't
happen
if we lived in a movie then sure you'd
simply
if you're the cop uh you'd shoot the
knife or whatever weapon out of the
perps hand
maybe deliver a couple a couple of
karate chops or roundhouse kicks
uh the suspect is knocked unconscious
just for long enough
to put them in cuffs and everyone gets
out alive
you know though and and um though maybe
the the badass tough-as-nails cop
gets chewed out by the police captain
you know
for for showboating as always that's the
way it goes in film
and the great thing about film is that
everything is neat
and it follows a certain structure and
there's no
random misery and death there might
there might be misery and death
but it serves the purpose of the story
and everything usually works out okay in
the end
that's the way it goes in movies again
that's not reality reality is messy
cops live in messi
all day there's no script you have to
make quick decisions
and you make the decision that has the
highest probability of bringing out the
least
bringing about the least horrible
outcome
you also can't guarantee that the bullet
is always going to go where you want it
to go
if you shoot for a hand which is a small
fast moving target
you'll probably miss and you'll hit
whatever or whoever is on on the other
side
of that hand and in this case um you
would have been hitting the very person
you were trying to save
if you shoot for the leg again a smaller
fast moving target
there's a good chance you'll miss and
then that means that the dangerous armed
assailant will succeed in causing
whatever harm they were trying to cause
to whoever they were trying to cause it
to also even if you hit the personal leg
again because this isn't a movie
they aren't going to automatically go
down
right they're not going to automatically
fall to their knees and start shaking
their fists
and saying ah foiled again you know no
they'll probably still be moving and
there's there's
there's no reason why in this case in
particular she couldn't have finished
the movement i mean she had her hand
back like this with a knife in it
um even if you shot her leg that's not
gonna stop her from doing this and
stabbing somebody
she could stab multiple times after
getting shot in the leg
remember in the real world all you can
do is choose the least
horrible outcome
in this case the most horrible outcome
in the
the bryant case is that the assailant
stabs an unarmed girl to death right in
front of you that is the most horrible
outcome from the perspective of a police
officer
you want to avoid that the least
horrible
is that you stop the assailant by the
quickest and most high percentage method
available
shooting center mass right in the chest
is it's not so that you'll have the
highest chance of killing them
it's so you'll have the highest chance
of stopping them from doing what they're
doing
sadly that often means killing them
that's not the point
the point is to stop them again least
horrible
messy situation i wish you didn't have
to be that way but it does
all you really have to do here to
understand why it has to be this way
is put yourself in the shoes of of the
girl who is about to get stabbed
okay and pause the tape right there and
imagine this you're pinned against a car
someone has a butcher knife they have
their arm all the way back
winding up you know with ready to thrust
that blade into your body
if it hits you in the heart you're dead
if she gets you in the gut
you might be dead or you might live with
internal organ damage or worse
if she gets you in the face you could be
dead you could be blind you could be
horribly disfigured
um you see a police officer right behind
her he has this gun out what do you want
him to do
in that situation what do you want him
to do right then and there
do you want him to choose a least a less
effective option to prevent you from
being butchered in hopes of also
preserving the life of the person trying
to butcher you
or do you want him to just stop her
now you probably if you if you notice
this and you were you were cognizant of
it you'd probably be shooting shoot her
shoot her
you want you want her to she's about to
stab you you want you want this to be
you know you don't want to be you don't
want to give your life
so that for the sake of your assailant
not being shot when they're trying to
stab you
um well you know what what would we what
would we all really want in that
situation
if we could have anything we would want
john wick to be there or or superman or
you know spider-man who can shoot his
webs
and uh you know put it put an end to it
we'd want that
but we can't have that and uh so
then what we're gonna have is a cop in
the real world and that means
least horrible outcome they shoot that's
the first talk about the second is this
uh what about dylan roof he was taken
alive
they bought him burger king
how scandalous is that well this one is
really simple
it's not even complex and messy like the
first one was
it's really easy dylan roof did a
horrific thing and was sentenced to
death for it
he was taken alive because he
surrendered peacefully
the only way to not take him alive would
have been to execute him on the spot
while he is clearly and unambiguously
surrendering now you might say the cops
have done that before
on rare occasion like they did to daniel
shaver uh yeah and
they have on rare occasions that's bad
okay we don't want them to do that
in almost every case they don't do that
and it's good that they don't do that
if j if dylann roof had drawn up on the
cops
they would have shot him dead in a
second and nobody would care without it
without any hesitation
if if dylan roof had wrestled the cops
and run away
and like reached into his car they would
have shot him dead right then and there
again nobody would
protest or care um
but he didn't do any of that and that's
why he survived
so that he could be sentenced to death
almost every black and white suspect who
surrenders peacefully
makes it out alive and that's how
in the few exceptions where they
surrender peacefully and are still
killed usually the cop is prosecuted so
there's no issue here um why was dylann
roof given burger king well because
he we have to feed bad guys in custody
it's a law
starve him refuse him food and water and
that's a good way of making sure the bad
guy walks free
the beltway snipers two two black people
serial killers who terrorize the
baltimore
dc area for weeks and i remember this
well
were taken alive and and and given food
while in custody
why because they surrendered peacefully
they didn't give the cops a reason to
shoot them
give the cops a valid reason to shoot
you and they might
so don't do that it's really not hard
it's not hard to refrain from attacking
the cops or fighting them or trying to
kill them
or trying to kill other people in front
of them that's that's not a hard thing
that's not a high bar to get over
it's not an unreasonable demand is it
it's not an infringement it's a very low
bar
don't fight the cops don't try to kill
them don't try to kill anybody in front
of the cops don't try to kill anybody
any
anytime even the cops aren't there you
know that's the most ideal scenario
um and just follow those basic rules of
life and uh you're not guaranteed
success and happiness but at the very
least you're probably not getting shot
by the cops
very very low bar if you can't clear
that very very very low bar you might
get shot
such is life and such is death
and that's the reality those who don't
understand it
or would deny it are you guessed it
canceled if you enjoyed this video be
sure to give it a thumbs up and share it
with all your friends